diese hedgefonds haben es verdient zu
brennen wir sind jetzt dem endspiel
halten es wird sich auszahlen userinnen
der online plattform rettet treiben den
kurs der gamestop aktie in die höhe und
große hedgefonds verlieren milliarden
als ich das am anfang war genommen habe
dass so was passiert doch statt den
hedgefonds gewinnen kleinanleger innen
die wette da ging es vor allem darum ein
bisschen teil einer bewegung zu sein
doch wer hat wirklich gewonnen wer
verloren wir sind die einpeitscher die
kommandeure dieser trading apps wenn sie
das gemacht haben nicht besser als die
hedgefonds manager selbst ich habe mich
gefragt wer sind die typen die die
großen aktien profis an der nase
herumgeführt haben und wie reagieren die
hedgefonds jetzt ist die rod community
die neue macht am aktienmarkt dazu werde
ich mit menschen sprechen die mitgemacht
haben bei dem run auf gamestop und wird
einem ehemaligen hedgefonds-manager ich
werde mich durch reddot foren und chats
in trading apps wühlen um herauszufinden
werden wir so etwas wie gamestop
häufiger erleben und ist das jetzt die
revolution auf dem aktienmarkt
[Musik]
erstmal müssen wir uns dafür den fall
gamestop noch mal genauer anschauen bei
gamestop da gibt es pc und
konsolenspiele muss so richtig auf
datenträger aber das problem ja ja immer
mehr gamer kaufen sich ihre spiele nur
online und nicht im einkaufszentrum dann
waren die läden durch corona noch
längere zeit geschlossen
das heißt gamestop ging es einfach schon
seit einiger zeit nicht so gut
die aktie lag ende juni juli vergangenen
jahres bei drei bis vier euro
zum vergleich guten zeiten maximal 340
euro aus diesen gründen haben diverse
finanzexperten das ende von gamestop
vorhergesagt und capital unternehmen und
hedgefonds haben darauf gewettet dass
die aktie von gamestop sinken wird diese
wette haben sie verloren aber schauen
wir uns erst mal an wie solche wetten
überhaupt funktionieren nämlich durch
leerverkäufe
was sind also leerverkäufe bei
leerverkäufen wetten dass der kurs von
einem bestimmten wertpapier feld
investorinnen meistens hedgefonds leihen
sich dabei gegen eine gebühr eine aktie
von anderen anlegern dann verkaufen sie
diese aktie und setzen darauf dass der
kurs sinkt bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo sie
die aktie dann wieder zurückgeben müssen
wenn der kurs gesunken ist kaufen sie
wieder diese aktie
die jetzt sehr günstiger ist und die
geben sie dann wieder zurück sie mussten
die leihgebühr zahlen aber die differenz
zwischen den betrag für den sie verkauft
haben und dem preis zu dem sie wieder
zurückgekauft haben die können die
investorinnen einstreichen
warum machen hedgefonds so was das würde
ich von einem wissen der selber schon
mal solche der verkäufer gemacht hat
short selling felix heise hat bayern
hedgefonds in new york gearbeitet und
betreibt jetzt selbst einen kleinen
fonds in frankfurt warum wartet man
darauf dass ein unternehmen verliert
dass es möglicherweise pleite geht warum
macht man das
manche shortseller haben haben eine sehr
wichtige markt funktion ja einfach das
kritische auge drauf zu sein und
deswegen man fühlt sich dann also ich
hatte noch nie der fall dass ich was
dass sich das bewusst herunter stürzen
wollte ja ich mit meiner position weiß
ich einfach nur darauf hin hier
da ist vielleicht ein exzess eine
übertreibung
und es hat auch ein bisschen der
schützende funktion für den kapitalmarkt
die gamestop aktie war wie gesagt schon
längere zeit relativ tiefen kurs der
hedgefonds add on research unter anderem
hat aber trotzdem monate lang behauptet
diese achse ist immer noch viel zu hoch
angesetzt und hat gleichzeitig muss nach
leerverkäufen macht wenn es jetzt sehr
viele leerverkäufe gibt dann kann das
ein angeschlagenes unternehmen massiv
unter druck setzen
in den usa können sogar mehr aktien leer
verkauft werden als überhaupt auf dem
markt sind das heißt bei gamestop waren
wohl zeitweise bis zu 140 prozent der
aktien leer verkauft
das geht durch sogenannte schatten
aktien das hat die reddot communitys
erkannt und sie haben ganz viele aktien
von gamestop gekauft so viele dass der
kurs nach oben und die hedgefonds sich
eindecken muss mit diesen teureren
aktien damit sie nicht noch mehr verlust
zu machen
stellen sie sich vor sie haben ein auto
das verkaufen sie zwei drei mal da ist
die hoffnung bitte sehr klar dass
natürlich nur einer nachfragt wenn die
anderen zwar auch nachfragen haben sie
ein problem dann müsste sie quasi autos
woanders nachkaufen so war es auch kein
hedgefonds sie waren sie gezwungen dann
zurück zu kaufen als sie gemerkt haben
der markt geht gar nicht runter geht
nach oben tatsächlich gibt es leute die
wollen dieses auto tatsächlich haben und
nicht nur einer sondern mehrere
da muss bei händeringend schauen wo
bekomme ich es weitere autos her die
hedge fonds mussten also die gamestop
aktien teuer von reddot userinnen und
anderen zurückkaufen sehr viel träumen
ende januar stand der kurs zeitweise bei
410 euro zur erinnerung im sommer statt
einmal bei 34 euro die hedgefonds an
massiv verluste allein im januar haben
sie durch die wetten dass der gamestop
kurs sinkt 12,5 milliarden dollar
verlust gemacht das zeigen daten von dem
datenanbieter ort ex einer der fonds ne
win capital hat sogar die hälfte seines
vermögens verloren andere fonds mussten
ihn mit einer finanzspritze retten ich
will wissen wer war dabei weil dies
flashmob an der börse der die hedgefonds
bluten lassen hat die ticken diese leute
sind das er ist innen kapitalismus
kritiker innen oder heavy trader innen
die einfach nur ein gutes geschäft
machen wollen
dafür müssen wir tiefer in die online
plattform rettet eintauchen in dem unter
führung der schweiz tauschen sich
mittlerweile mehr als acht millionen
user innen über strategien im kampf
gegen etablierte börsenhändler innen aus
das forum gibt es schon seit 2012 mit
dem game stop sind die mitgliederzahlen
jetzt aber abrupt gestiegen
hier gibt es analysen absprachen und
eine ganze menge - und wallstreet betz
gründer jamie rosinski sieht die aktion
tatsächlichen geist von occupy wall
street der kapitalismuskritischen
protestbewegungen stadt besetzung auf
der straße versucht wall street betz die
hedgefonds wird ihren eigenen waffen zu
schlagen was jetzt erreicht wird ist das
was occupy wallstreet versucht hat und
woran sie gescheitert sind eine
machtverschiebung eine verlagerung eines
teils der kontrolle von der wall street
zum mainstreet auf dem deutschen ableger
von horst schmidbauer straßen wetten
wenn ich mehr über den weg kunde
erfahren und finde überraschend
emotionale wütende beiträge euch einfach
alle hart ihr gebt uns keine faire
möglichkeit auf rentier gibt in vielen
jungen menschen in einer
jahrhundertkrise keinen fairen rückhalt
und dann seid ihr ja noch wütend wenn
wir in jamie investieren weil eure alten
freunde zu gierig geworden sind und wir
jetzt gewinnen könnten
ich halte ich werde nie aufhören zu
halten und ich werde nachdenken einfach
weil ich es kann
und weil jeder sind den ich in bmi
stecke irgendeinem knaller da draußen
schnappatmung verpasst der verfasser
dieses beitrags schreibt erst mitte 30
hat zwei berufsbegleitende master und er
macht sich sorgen um die rente der
künftigen generationen ich habe ihn
angeschrieben und gefragt ob er mit mir
sprechen will
aber er will lieber anonym bleiben ich
soll den fragen per e mail schicken
antworten habe ich aber bisher keine
bekommen deswegen suche ich weiter auf
reddit ich will eine der kleinanleger
erinnern in echt kennenlernen arbeiten
lohnt sich einfach nicht mehr
es gibt keine ziele wenn man sie hat
nimmt sie irgendwer
dann weg die wall street ist unsere
verdammte elterngeneration und ihre
eigenheime sowie querdenker schwabe ley
man reißt sich den arsch schaffen was zu
erreichen bzw sich überhaupt eine basis
für später aufzubauen und wird von den
blumen dafür belächelt den verfasser von
dem letzten kommentar ich angeschrieben
auch er möchte nicht dass wir ihnen
zeigen oder seinen namen nennen er sagt
er hat da einfach angst um seine
karriere aber erst bereit mit uns zu
telefonieren der user nennen wir ihn
torben ist 29 und it projektmanager er
würde sich jetzt gerade eigentlich ganz
gerne ein haus kaufen jetzt ist das
alter sagt er aber im wohngebiet kostet
als eine halbe million euro in dem
ballungsgebiet gezogen aus job gründen
nach meinem studium habe dann noch
berufsbegleitend weiter studiert mbl
gemacht und letztendlich sehe ich jetzt
auch mit überdurchschnittlichem
einkommen das auf kurze sicht keine
immobilie zum beispiel kaufen kann
sondern dass ich mir dann sehr gut
überlegen musste ob ich denn mal kinder
in die welt setzen will
zum hinblick darauf ob man sowas dann
überhaupt bis zur rente ab bezahlt
kriegt uns die situation bei mir und ich
denke so geht es vielen rathaus hat er
sich jetzt für eine große mietwohnung
entschieden er will fürs alter vorsorgen
und investiert da normalerweise eher in
sichere anlagen im november ist er beim
wall street aber auf gamestop gestoßen
und hat 700 euro investiert für solche
sachen setzt man die menge an geld wie
man auch verkraften kann komplett zu
verlieren
so sollte man das so machen ich kann mir
gut vorstellen dass andere leute das
vielleicht auch nicht machen ein
bisschen risikofreudiger sind aber für
mich war das in dem sinne spiegel ist
nichts anderes als ins kasino zu gehen
für ihn hat nicht die wette gelohnt sein
gewinn 500 prozent das sind 3500 euro
also dagegen noch steuern ab aber
trotzdem nicht schlecht einer der ersten
die bei dieser wette all in gegangen
sind ist übrigens dieser youtube ab der
sich auf relativ fucking value nennt
schon 2009 10 ist er eingestiegen hat
die entwicklungen um gamestop analyse
und insgesamt 50.000 euro gesetz
gewonnen hatte einen zweistelligen
millionen für diese riskante wette wird
er auf wallstreet betz als held gefeiert
aber zurück zu den deutschen redet
userinnen bei meiner recherche stoße ich
auf den bayern auf instagram hat er den
account nasdaq id aufgebaut wo er über
aktien und finanzen informiert er will
offen mit uns sprechen auch er hat
gamestop aktien gekauft warum da ging es
vor allem darum ein bisschen teil einer
bewegung zu sein von der sozialen
dynamik und der der betrag da spielte
gar nicht so die große große rolle nicht
damit ein paar stück dabei gehabt dann
eben auch profit mitgenommen das macht
dann jeder so ein bisschen für sich aus
mit 18 hat jahren seine erste aktie
gekauft jetzt ist er 22
er studiert wirtschaftswissenschaften
und normalerweise setzt auch er auf
sichere anlageformen gamestop hat er
eine ausnahme gemacht ging es dir darum
den hedgefonds ist jetzt mal zu zeigen
oder war das ein teil von der motivation
also für mich war es eher ein bisschen
mehr aus aus aus willst muss ich sagen
weil ich mir natürlich auch die
reportagen angeguckt haben zb von cnbc
von also diesen ja den natürlichen
normalen börsenmedien sagen wir mal
je größer die die aufschreie wurden dass
man da regulieren soll ja durch eine
situation die eigentlich ein hedgefond
herbeigeführt hat und die es auch schon
länger an diesem system gibt umso
witziger wurde ist dann tatsächlich für
mich und auch viele die ich kenne
weil man sich das angeschaut dann
gedacht dieses finanzsystem so wie es
jetzt ist das haben wir ja nicht wieder
in anführungsstrichen oder die jungen
leute vielleicht gut gemacht ja das ist
existiert ja jetzt schon etliche jahre
für die reddot userinnen wobei es vor
allem männer sind scheint es mehrere
gründe zum mitmachen gegeben zu haben
den einen den dünn ist und schnelle geld
die anderen wollten den hedgefonds eins
auswischen und wieder anderen ging es
vielleicht einfach nur um den spaß
was uns zu der frage bringt ist das
jetzt die große aktien revolution neben
gamestop hat die community auch auf
andere angeschlagene unternehmen
im gesetz zum beispiel auf die kinokette
msi auf das deutsche batterie
unternehmen weiter und auf die
biotechfirma evotec aktien ging es erst
mal so hoch und jetzt spannend es auf
etwas höherem niveau
die gangster praxis ist aber jetzt auch
schon wieder deutlich abgestürzt und
viele kleinanleger innen die ihm kurz
vor dem höhepunkt eingestiegen sind die
haben jetzt große verluste gemacht so
wahrheit gehört eben auch die
einpeitscher die die kleinanleger die
doch nie mit aktien teil was war
teilweise was zu tun hat gar keine
ahnung hatten in dem sinne die in den
markt zu jagen und oben selbst zu
verkaufen
wer die truppen unten noch kämpfen das
ist natürlich etwas wo ich sagen muss
hier sind die einpeitscher die
kommandeure dieser trading apps wenn sie
das gemacht haben nicht besser als die
hedgefonds manager selbst robert halver
glaubt nicht dass phänomene wie wall
street betz größere auswirkungen auf den
gesamten aktienmarkt haben werden
im zweifel wird er reguliert sagt er und
interessantes detail auch profi anleger
haben im fall gamestop profitiert der
hedge fonds management zum beispiel hat
700 millionen dollar gewinn gemacht weil
er zum richtigen zeitpunkt ausgestiegen
ist das berichtet zumindest das wall
street journal
der ehemalige hedgefonds manager felix
eisele findet mit solchen reddot
dynamiken muss man leben aber etwas
anderes bereitet ihm sorgen
es ist ein ungleiches problem und es
zeigt sich also ins dilemma entweder
auch mitmachen bei dieser party und das
ist ja was einem ihrer sorge bereiten
muss ja diese diese schere die weiter
entsteht ja und tun muss man leben aber
ja diese diese feindlichkeit zwischen
kriegen
der wall street und kleinanleger und das
beste was ein eher sorge bereitet
höheren bayer der gamestop aktien
gekauft hat der glaubt dass baskets den
hedge fonds einen denkzettel verpasst
hat und dass solche aktionen öfters
vorkommen könnten ja ich denke schon
dass es auf jeden fall auch eine aktion
war um eben den hedgefonds auch mal oder
den ganzen finanzsystem meinen
angestrichen eine lehre zu erteilen weil
man jetzt auch natürlich auf diesen
plattformen unglaublich gewachsen ist
so dass das solches szenario theoretisch
ja wieder vorkommen kann ja dass man
eben daraus lernt und das daneben sich
hedgefonds solche aktionen wie in diesen
wird weder gamestop aktie jetzt nicht
mehr so trauen der fall gamestop hat
große wellen geschlagen in den usa
untersuchen die aufsichtsbehörden den
fall und auch die deutsche
finanzaufsichtsbehörde bafin prüft nach
ob das jetzt eine revolution auf dem
aktienmarkt ist ob die trader innen von
wall street sich als neue macht auf dem
aktienmarkt etablieren werden oder erst
mal genug haben von diesen wetten dass
wird sich zeigen
auf reddit jedenfalls hoffen sie dass
das erst der anfang ist bleibt drin
damit wir den markt verändern können
das ist nur der anfang kam für die
gewinne blieb für die revolution
[Musik]
was haltet ihr von dem was mit der
gamestop aktien den vergangenen wochen
passiert ist habt ihr vielleicht sogar
selbst investiert und gewonnen oder
verloren schreibt uns in die kommentare
hier oben habe ich euch einen zoomin
verlinkt indem wir geschaut haben die
junge menschen fürs alter vorsorgen
können und hier unten findet ihr diesen
playlist schauen gerne vorbei